you just put what can you put that stuff
on iTunes so people get excessive well I
will no I'm bad at that you know but I
should I will that hard no it's not hard
I just I you're right I need to thank
you know I guess what I'm saying here's
the thing about you - oh what about you
- well you just said here's here's the
thing about you - yeah here it is
yeah it is great I was gonna say okay I
don't know you [ __ ] bottle what say
does he just have nodes or is he like
sick she's got a tracheotomy no way you
are a real the top story does say bono
says he doesn't know if you two will
tour again wait but he has a trach like
he actually has a hole in his yeah
remember that movie no country for old
yeah yeah I had that gun that would
shoot holes through doors yeah
bono got hit a hole on his throat I kept
enough from that oh not from an Eric
thing I think it just says a sore throat
them I think all right guy no no country
for old men whoa he's got Ireland I
wonder if bono gets a morning bono oh
wait he did have throat cancer in 2000
haha
you're right you're right but his second
brush with but the second brush with
mortality had nothing to do with his
throat it was a high-energy bicycle
accident into his throat throat by a
bicycle man who's he laying on the side
maybe they're like little tiny bites elf
spikes yeah yeah you also go to Burning
Man right yeah do you go every year I
went three years in a row I didn't go
this year but the last three before that
I regretted not going this year I really
I wake I woke up every morning like why
aren't I there and who do you go in
first year I kind of went by myself and
the second year I went with my buddy
Michael Rosenbaum and then last year I
went with my buddy Dan and I think I'm
gonna go next year you know it's funny I
there's such a stigma you know on like
just people who go to Burning Man in
general like you know the LA types but I
never if there was a you seem like the
perfect person to go to Burning Man with
if I ever if I could ever think of
anybody I would want to go with you seem
like that would be I would allow it
selfish
yeah I'm selfish and when it comes to
that dude why can't I take your
girlfriend away in a hamper for five
days that's my girl okay yeah okay mr.
Scrooge bah humbug just call me mr.
Scrooge bro with your beautiful what
would you do what would you do out there
with her in the desert like ask her what
would you do with Harlow Williams we
would just waltz around the ply I'd cook
good food baby you know hey no need to
no I do need to know man because
I know you out there they don't take
money they trade services what you want
to get a sandwich you're gonna sell her
a little [ __ ] out
stop right now
whoa bro you want a sandwich you guys
sell my little girl's [ __ ] out
for a [ __ ] meatball sandwich don't do
that dude that's the [ __ ] human being
right there man I'm never gonna go to
Burning Man and for the rest of my life
why I don't like it I don't like the
desert
I don't like um fire I don't like drums
about sushi yeah before you had it did
you know you'd like it or not like it
actually do you remember the first time
you probably thought I'm not eating raw
fish this is gross and now it's all you
eat bro I can smell it in your gums Ryan
you just you know what that was wise
what you just didn't you turned it
around
there's the thing everyone I know
including myself was reluctant to go to
Burning Man I I was skeptical I kind of
like sounds Rosenbaum my buddy rosey he
didn't want to go I said let's just go
man just just go put your feet trust me
and he goes okay I'm trust he didn't
want to go he must have stopped five 10
15 times while we were walking around
and just stopped grab my shoulder went
bro I love you this is the best thing
I've ever done it's really a magical
it's a magical place
but right off its top halt why you know
it's like sushi if you've never don't
you don't use the sushi Trevor no but
what I'm saying is if you had never had
sushi mugo I know you already did
tell me what sushi tastes like I could
say well it tastes like this it tastes
like that you go okay but you'd never
know until you put it in your mouth and
you go oh wow that's what it tastes like
and Burning Man I could sit here for the
rest of the show and tell you all about
it but it's truly one of those places
you have to land there and be there and
and you you understand it it's really
hard to describe it really is I I went
through the same thing I will you
drugged-out know I'm you know me I'm not
one I'm not a druggie guy I'm not a
drinky guy and you are now you are and
no you're not not really yeah you know
but did you do drugs out there father a
lot of people do drugs I do do drugs out
there I think I might a saw a guy that
looked like me you know everyone yeah
that guy that you that looks like you
that guy that looks like you that was
out there in the desert
yeah the first time first time I went
yeah I had a few beers cuz I'm not a big
drinker but didn't do much of anything
right second time I might have had a
little weed okay and that was fun okay
do you smoke weed it in LA no I really
don't ever once a year yeah if that if
that yeah right so out there it's just
an interesting place and everyone thinks
you have to do drugs or do something you
don't there's I don't know much about
that's why I'm asking questions man you
can go out and do nothing you can go I
drove you know I drove out with two
sober people last year I drove to sober
be their sober people there's it's
everybody so it's what you make it but
it's really fantastic can I ask you
another question when you go out there
do you get some
yeah it's there if you want it how do
you participate I have not no it's it's
weird because there's so much going on
out there there's so much stimuli that
it wasn't part of my agenda like I
didn't really think about it like
there's so much other neat stuff that
you're never gonna see anywhere else in
the world so you're focused on that
stuff because you're not gonna you're
not gonna be anywhere that's like that
it's almost like remember the old Star
Trek yeah with with William Shatner and
they beam down and also they're on this
weird planet and it it's like that it's
almost like twice like this it's mad
mats people have chrome in their face
it's part of that right and there and
there they look like [ __ ] they live
from the hills they the tribally mmm you
know and then I don't know if I should
run or [ __ ] you know I mean dude you
know if you stand still too long life
passes you by mm-hmm
this [ __ ] with the sushi and now
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] don't forget ba
nose hole yeah yes a hole is throat you
know the bikes
[Music]